hi I'm Erik Bosse that Marvel phase four
will first expand to the Disney Plus
streaming world with the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier the announcement at Comic
Con and other reveals since have given
us some interesting insights into this
new series and how it will explore the
change landscape of the MCU post endgame
and post far from home hopefully it'll
be more than Anthony Mackie and
Sebastian Stan trading sized jokes
though let's be honest we'd still watch
it it's more rewarding for everything
Marvel related I might talking about
everything post Comic Con including
endgame and far from home deal with it
okay so Falcon Winter Soldier will
release on Disney Plus in fall 2020
maybe as soon as I guess 2020 it'll be a
limited series with six episodes
directed by Corey Skoglund who has
directed episodes of Marvel's the
Punisher on Netflix The Handmaid's Tale
and The Walking Dead writing the series
will be Malcolm Spellman of Empire and
John wick creator Derek Kolstad this
sounds like fieger's will be more
hands-on with the creative process on
this one
to make sure it more firmly ties in with
the MCU than Marvel Netflix series did
so we aren't just looking at an
occasional reference to the Battle of
New York this will be a truly integrated
world some plot rumors have suggested
that Falcon and Bucky will still be
considered enemies of the state as they
were before the infinity war in in-game
events with Thunderbolt Ross out there
still probably upset about their Civil
War betrayals and getting hung up on by
Rhodey
now one would hope that CV the goddamn
universe in the Battle of Earth might
earn them some pardons yet still one
theory out there is that this show will
feature the US government pushing
against the idea of Sam Wilson taking
over the mantle of Captain America
Anthony Mackie has said that he will
appear in a new Captain America suit of
his own in the show he confirmed in an
interview I just had my first fitting no
you don't I did tell me it looks really
good that's my question where I'm
putting them so it's not totally clear
if he will still have the Falcon wings
as well as cap shield either way I don't
think Sam Wilson will get a new suit and
gear like this without some kind of
institutional support it'll just be
interesting to see what the world's
institutions will look like post blip
spider-man far from home suggested that
things like public schools passport
offices airport security they're doing a
decent job picking up the pieces
meanwhile Nick Fury's operation seems to
be in conjunction with some dummy
scrolls I speculated that he could have
launched soared to orbit and protect the
Earth from the peak so we just don't
know how all of this will leave world
security forces on the ground level we
do know that Emily VanCamp will also be
joining this cast as Asian thirteen
Sharon Carter last seen by Falcon and
Bucky is she was smooch and Steve and
Civil War and this is before he went
back in time and actually hooked up with
her great aunt okay maybe the Black
Widow movie coming in May 20 20 could
shed some light on this world that movie
will bounce back and forth between
Natasha in her years also on the run
after her Civil War betrayal but also
the years earlier in Budapest and maybe
it'll establish the existence of a
covert spy organization with Yelena
Bulova and red Guardian the seeds of a
future Dark Avengers movie which could
connect with winners soldier's story but
all this would set the stage for Falcon
and winter soldiers villain revealed
that comic-con - the Baron Zemo from
Civil War he interrupted the panel in a
video with a list of Hydra Winter
Soldier activation words longing rested
17 day break furnace nine benign
homecoming one freight car oh I should
have said them out loud we got him again
brew later reposted images of this war
cameo on his Instagram and which he get
a good look of him in zimos classic
purple mask appearance from the comics
so what is the most secret plan how is
he gonna come after Falcon and Winter
Soldier well the last we saw of Zemo he
was apprehended by black panther at the
end of civil war and in the movie Black
Panther we saw some news reports
explaining his arrest now remember his
original plan and Civil War was to turn
the Avengers against each other to seek
revenge for the deaths of his family and
the sokovia event in age of Ultron Zemo
did this by accessing hydras Winter
Soldier program and brainwashing Bucky
to commit various acts of terror which
would inevitably drive a wedge between
Stark and cap which it did but now with
stark a cop out of the picture woods emo
still have this grudge is really gonna
spend all this time chasing down old man
cap just kicking down doors of nursing
homes who own people away like Walter
White or would he hold Falcon
responsible
well since the comic-con appearance
showed Zemo in his purple mask from the
comics and fight over to him as Baron
Zemo his name and title from the comics
maybe the plan is to adapt his agenda
from the comics the formation
of the thunderbolts in the Marvel Comics
the Thunderbolts appear as a group of
supposed heroes to fill the void after
The Avengers were declared dead in the
onslaught event but we find out at the
end of the first issue that the
Thunderbolts are actually villains in
disguise organized by Baron Zemo from
his former supervillain group the
Masters of evil including beetle fixer
moonstone and screamin Mimi
as the Thunderbolts they all take on new
aerobic patriotic identities Zemo
becomes American citizen V stealing the
look from a world war 2 era hero that
his father killed beetle becomes Mach 1
fixer becomes techno screaming meanie
becomes songbird Goliath joins a group
to become Atlas over time these other
members of the Thunderbolts find
Redemption and become known as reformed
superheroes who overturn zimos
leadership now I have speculated that
Marvel phase 4 might do something
similar
following Mysterio's example and far
from home with impostor superheroes
billing the Avengers void but actually
possessing secret villainous agendas but
I could also see Baron Zemo manipulating
events in a similar way consider the
blip plane into Z Mo's escape either the
guards at his prison cell got dusted
away or he himself got dusted but then
blipped back after the prison cell was
moved or remodeled over the five years
perhaps his first move in would be to
track down Bucky Barnes and use the same
Winter Soldier activation words to
control him and then from that build a
league of thunderbolt heroes to become
the new Avengers of this world that
might also include figures like Yelena
Bulova the new black widow they would
all be operating in a world post
Mysterio the great martyr according to
the Daily Bugle so they could pick up
where Mysterio's fake news left off
adding Sam Wilson to the list along with
Peter Parker of disgraced former
Avengers who don't deserve to inherit
the mantles of their successors now the
challenge of the good guys here would be
to overthrow Zemo as the head of this
league win over the public and then use
the leftover redemptive heroes and the
ranks to lay the groundwork for a new
true Avengers lineup in phase 4 and
beyond what do you think of this idea
and what do you think zimos plan will be
in Falcon and the Winter Soldier comment
down below with your thoughts and follow
me on instagram at twitter at da boss
and subscribe to new rock stars or
breakdowns and theories about everything
marvel
thank you for joining me and i'm calling
now Falcon and Winter Soldier is gonna
feature one of them saying at some point
I could do this all if something will
hit them and cut them off yeah it's
definitely gonna happen
[Music]